[Music]
Pinterest is the best place to go if you
are looking for inspiration for a DIY
project however it's easier said than
done and many people find out they are
not as good as they thought at least
they have exactly what it takes to make
us laugh out loud make sure you watch
this video until the end to know what
truly happens when you put a baby in a
pumpkin do you have any hilarious
Pinterest fails of your own click the
link in the description and send us your
Pinterest fails for a chance to be
featured in our next video the string
balloons this project seemed really
simple and we couldn't wait to see these
amazing results these string balloons
are a perfect decoration for your living
room or a party outside with your
friends it looks fun to make and then
you can enjoy this beautiful decoration
all summer long seeing one of our
beautiful creations is a good way to
make a smile every day but unfortunately
for most people the string balloons will
only make them laugh according to the
instructions you're supposed to soak the
yarn in Mod Podge wrap it around a
balloon and let it dry then you pop the
balloon and the strings are supposed to
stay in place to create a unique
decoration unfortunately these people
were surprised to see that this is not
what happens they followed all the
instructions but we think that the only
thing they missed is that they didn't
wait long enough that's why their
artwork all fell apart when they popped
the balloon and we can totally
understand why they were disappointed if
we didn't hear about this story we
wouldn't think that this weird and sad
colorful thing was supposed to be that
beautiful string balloon at least there
is one thing that they learned from this
next time they will use lighter strings
and make sure that they wait a little
bit longer before it dries that's just a
great reason to try again the cartoon
makeup Finster's is one of the best
websites any makeup artists can use to
find new ideas no matter what you're
looking for you will always find a lot
of beautiful looks that you can use as
an inspiration to turn yourself into a
beauty queen however don't think that
all you need is
eeeh you also need the skills and that's
why I only professional makeup artists
can really recreate the perfect look so
watching makeup tutorials on YouTube for
the past month probably wasn't enough
you also need to practice this time a
women thought that this party makeup was
so easy that she wouldn't have to wear a
costume after all when you first take a
look at it you think that you just need
to draw black lines on your face and
then add some dots then you can also
wear big fake eyelashes and put on some
red lipstick but this woman found out
the hard way
that it was much harder than it seems
she drew dark lines at all the wrong
places
and just gave up before painting the dot
as she said herself the result of this
failure led to a truly inspirational
dress at Frida Kahlo we guessed that she
is just going to have to dress up as the
famous painter for Halloween this time
we just hope that she won't be painting
on anyone's face the Hogwarts cake
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry is absolutely the best school
in the world yes it might be a little
dangerous to be there when you can fall
down the stairs get lost in the forest
or meet fall des morts any time but is
it still worth it one of the things that
we loved the most was the food all the
students have a chance to eat three
delicious meals every day with more food
than they could asked for and we are
wondering why we can't have the same
thing in muggle schools we don't ignite
to provide food for all the students
after all this is why this mother and
her daughter decided to bring joy to
everyone at the birthday party by baking
a cake inspired by Hogwarts and the four
houses we don't know how but they
thought it looks reasonably easy to do
they thought that they could just bake
drawer color layers and insert frosting
between them however the mother made one
big mistake she didn't follow the cake
recipe in the pin and used regular
yellow cake instead because she didn't
think that the kids would like spice
cake that's probably what explains why
it was not sturdy enough to hold the
frosting no it just looks like they
dropped the cake on the floor but as
long as it tastes good kids probably
won't mind eating it the cutout dress
why buy new clothes when you can create
a whole new outfit with old shirts that
you have at home that's a great way to
save money and look
Niek as none of your friends are going
to have the same look if the
fashionistas on Pinterest can do it you
can do it too right this time the model
looks stunning with her cutout dress it
was perfect for a summer day at the
beach or walking around town with our
friends we know we were not going to
have the same perfect body by wearing
the same dress but we can at least
aspire to look like her according to the
instructions you simply have to cut a
t-shirt in half and then tie it back
together it seems really simple but as
the young woman herself said this is
another one of Pinterest dirty dirty
lives after chopping up a t-shirt like a
drunk toddler she tied the two pieces
together to create the illusion of a
chic dress unfortunately only someone
who is blind could believe that she was
really ready to party she just looks
like her clothes had been attacked by a
wild cat next time she will probably use
a tighter longer shirt instead of
ruining in the old baggy t-shirt we will
have to agree with what she said there's
always more old t-shirts to slaughter
just don't touch our clothes please the
Easter eggs Easter is the perfect time
of the year to have fun with some eggs
and paint them with every color of the
rainbow no one really understands why a
rabbit with late chocklit eggs now we
would then have to find what does it
even have to do with Jesus but let's
stop asking ourselves too many questions
all that we care about is that there are
candies to eat and fun to have and what
a better way to spend a Sunday afternoon
then by dyeing real eggs for the shaving
cream it looks like something that kid
would be able to do so why not try it
unfortunately those who tried this DIY
we're not able to explain what they did
because they just didn't follow the
instructions at all however they have to
admit but they did die a wall next to
their crafts table blue and yellow
that's at least one thing they can use
to celebrate Easter unfortunately when
you look at the eggs you just feel sorry
for these people instead of being bright
and colorful they just look rotten they
had to admit that they will just get a
real egg dyeing kit next time and we
think that's a good idea
at least they didn't waste the eggs they
will still be good for breakfast but
next more
the gingerbread house another day that
we love to celebrate is Christmas and
holidays also come with a lot of days
off to have fun with our friends and
family there are so many people that we
want to see that we end up just sitting
on the couch binge watching our favorite
shows and drinking hot chocolate but if
there is one lazy thing that we have to
do it's playing with food and by that we
mean making our own gingerbread house a
lot of kids do that every year so it
should be easy right there are even some
kits that you can buy at the grocery
store to make things easier then you
just need a friend to help you while you
put the whole thing together then comes
the fun part when you can add a lot of
candies to decorate your new creation
and there you go you got a beautiful
house unfortunately not using the right
ingredients ruined the whole thing this
person used a lot of ganache before they
found out that it was not sippy no
matter how much ganache they added to
their creation the walls of the little
house wouldn't stay in place and this is
how they ended up with this disaster
let's get rid of this mess immediately
by eating it that's the only thing we
can do for the family picture since this
is a must-have for anyone who is
interested in photography this is the
best way to go find the pictures that
you will use as an inspiration and
recreate something in your own way it's
crazy to think that you can capture a
moment like that and make rice look so
much more beautiful for a moment this
couple is getting prepared for their
family picture with their newborn and
found this beautiful picture on
Pinterest they couldn't think of a
better way to show their love for each
other in a picture all they had to do
was to both kiss the baby on the cheeks
at the same time this is something that
they do every day so it shouldn't be
that hard right the photographer had
everything set to recreate this
beautiful moment but they quickly found
out that someone was not really
interested in this idea as soon as they
kissed their child he started crying as
the couple said their child was not as
enamoured as the kid in the original
picture was and when they think about
what they are going to do next time they
think that they should not try it at all
but we can't really say that this is at
interest fail that
because this picture looks even better
than the original because it will always
make them smile 3 the flourless muffins
anyone who is intolerant to gluten knows
that it's hard to find something to eat
during the first weeks after your doctor
tells you about it it seems like there
is gluten in just everything and if you
had to accept the fact that there are
many things that you are not going to
eat anymore like cereals cake or muffins
this is why some people came up with a
nice recipes like flourless muffins this
person was ready to finally eat a
dessert that they didn't get the chance
to taste for years but it was too late
when they realize that they didn't use
their right ingredients to make these
muffins they needed to use frozen
bananas but they had been saving it for
bread so they were probably too moist
this is how they ended up with these
blobs that they can't really call
muffins they baked it for 60 minutes
hoping it would dry out but it didn't
happen we don't even know how to call
those but it doesn't look like something
we should put in our mouth this is why
they concluded that next time they would
buy the expensive gluten-free muffins
instead but we still have to admit that
it must be difficult for anyone to make
something without gluten so we can at
least say that they were great for
trying
the ELMO cake what a better way to
celebrate a birthday than with our
favorite character on television the
kids will love it so much that they
won't even want to eat the cake and we
have to admit as grown-ups we would love
to see Elmo and our birthday party -
this is why someone knew that they
needed to recreate this cake as soon as
they saw this picture on Pinterest and
we think that there was already a little
veil in the original picture don't you
think that the shape between Elmo's legs
is a little inappropriate it took us a
moment to understand that it's actually
the number one and not something that
only men have anyway the second cake is
just worse this person tried to make
this cake with Rice Krispies but
everything was just too heavy to stay up
we also think that they just didn't have
the right thing to put the icing on the
cake and no just pouring it on this poor
creature wasn't the best idea there was
still some hope with the eyes in the
nose but they just ruined everything
with the red icing now
Elmo just looks terrifying there is no
way we are going to be able to use him
unless it's for a Halloween party but if
you need someone to take care of this
cake we are always here to eat it the
baby pumpkin when the leaves start to
fall and it gets a little colder outside
everyone knows that it's pumpkin time we
will drink pumpkin spice lattes at
Starbucks will carve one for Halloween
and we will bake a homemade pumpkin pie
people even love the pumpkin trim so
much that they want to involve their
child in this normal people would just
carve a scary face in their pumpkin when
it came to inside it and let it outside
of their home but these parents decided
to carve their pumpkins to put a baby in
it we thought that it was a weird idea
and how we saw the picture on Pinterest
and understood that it's really cute
unfortunately not every kid wants to be
involved in this project his parents did
their best to make sure that he was
comfortable by putting a clean rag in
the pumpkin unfortunately it wasn't
enough for the baby and he started
crying but his parents didn't care and
they took the picture anyway we think
that this young boy won't be proud of
this picture when he grows up
he will probably think that he has the
weirdest parents in the world were you a
victim of another Pinterest fail don't
be shy to tell us what happened in the
comment section down below we'd love to
hear what you think and that's it for 10
most hilarious Pinterest fails ever for
more stories like this make sure you
watch fifteen genius examples of
textbook vandalism by bored students
thanks for watching
[Music]